but first up he is a writer actor and
director known for the film's recount
and game changes lettuce project
dopesick is an acclaimed limited series
on hulu about the opioid epidemic
starring michael keaton please welcome
danny strong
how are you
so glad we're back to shaking hands oh
that's nice yes
all right well listen i just first want
to say to you your ability to turn
serious subjects into grand
entertainment is very impressive because
you don't take on easy things you take
on elections uh now you're the opioid
crisis and i just want to ask you first
of all
everybody should see this because it's
about something that's still going on
big time in this country um sometimes
movies tv shows inspire real change in
the real world has
the light you've shown on this done that
at all yeah it's been uh really
rewarding and exciting to see that
there's actually been some impact here i
mean i've done projects where you
thought they were going to have impact
and they ended up having no impact but
in this case uh we've seen the names
come down the sacral name come down from
multiple museums right after this okay
so the sacrifice of people don't know
that's the people and
the head of purdue pharmaceuticals who
were selling
mostly oxycontin is the opioid we're
talking about right yeah they're the
family
owned and micromanaged purdue pharma uh
which brought the country oxycontin
which was all based upon a lie the whole
drug was a con that it was non-addictive
when in fact it was highly addictive and
this drug is what created the opioid
crisis it wasn't a lie that it was fun
well that's you know
it was fun for some but for others i
don't know i mean
the reason always i mean the bottom i'm
not saying these people are innocent
they're not they probably should be in
jail but uh the reason why you know
drugs are popular is they do work
let's just say drugs you know kids don't
do drugs
in the case of in the case of oxycontin
it was it was you know marketed as a
non-addictive narcotic and so drug our
doctors were prescribing it to patients
uh thinking it was safe that it was
revolutionary when in fact it was the
opposite it was highly addictive so you
think the doctors didn't know
uh i think some did for sure but i don't
think it was uh doctors knew in this
widespread way i think there were
corrupt doctors
at some point they did
um when people started begging
and robbing drug stores for it i would
say these doctors should have known if
if if they were feigning they didn't you
know especially when you've got a
complaint at a certain point where he's
clearly addicted but in your show the
doctor michael keaton
himself gets hooked on it yeah okay well
that's the thing
i mean doctors for they have a lot of
access to drugs
you know you don't have to beg anybody a
prescription sure write your own name it
depends on the state you're in but but
yes there were doctors that absolutely a
got addicted to this drug yeah or b you
know it's really interesting doctors do
a lot again because it's right there
sure and some
genuinely just become addicted to it
yeah but there was also a push by
hospitals
to push doctors into prescribing opioids
to make sure patients didn't leave in
pain so they wouldn't get bad reviews on
wine so there's been a pressure
from hospitals on to doctors to
prescribe opioids right so what so
should the family the sackler family i
know they paid a six billion dollar
fine fine okay
after they made 10 billion probably more
right yeah
and corporations do this they
people dying is collateral damage to
profits very often and they write it
into the okay well six billion will
still make four billion you know mm-hmm
so should they go to jail absolutely
absolutely there are members of the
sackwer family uh that absolutely belong
in jail uh one of their big talking
points is that because purdue pharma the
company that they micromanaged and ran
has pled guilty to three felonies and
nine billion dollars in fines but none
of the individuals that ran that company
i.e the sackler family none of them have
ever been charged with a crime and you
know crimes don't commit themselves uh
there are people that are making these
decisions it's a great injustice that's
really a rerun of what we've saw on with
tobacco at some point they knew sure it
was it's it's more outrageous than the
tibetan story because they knew
immediately out of the gate it was a con
they created fake blood charts fake
studies fake slogans and let's be honest
none of this is possible
without partners in government
you know absolutely a great part of this
show is the revolving door showing the
revolving door yeah
just well it's one of the most egregious
things uh that i think we see in the
show is how
members of the government that are
supposed to be overseeing in regulating
purdue pharma in fact give them
everything they want and then go work
for them at a higher salary i mean that
literally happened the gentleman's name
was curtis wright he should be in jail
too in my opinion right i believe he's
committed a great crime on the american
people by what he's done by by you know
uh permitting this label that said the
drug was less addictive it wasn't and
then he goes and works for purdue pharma
18 months later yeah and they approve
things i mean a senator in this country
once said you can you can get any any
result you want
from a survey
from a testing of drugs and so forth if
you write a big enough check
um
and also i think
most people don't sound like trump most
people don't know
most people don't know this
but this is a real one
most people don't know that there's only
two countries in the world that allow
direct to advertise direct to consumer
advertising for prescription drugs new
zealand i don't know why that's the
other one but but we're the other one
two countries out of the whole world
think this is a great idea to tell
people in ads on television tell your
doctor well then he's just a pusher yeah
yeah you know hey doc i saw something on
tv that makes me want to just walk
through a wheat field with a smile on my
face
can i get that
you know
you